[Applause]
give me one minute and i'll show you how
data studio can put your data to work
giving you powerful exploration and
visualization tools to tell stories with
your data
you can think of data studio as that
all-in-one power adapter that lets you
charge any device in your household
it can take an energy which you can
think of as data and then use that
energy to power any device
like reports data studio connects to
many different sources allowing them
to quickly pull ads data sql databases
bigquery tables and sheets into its
processing and transformation tools
a strong query language along with
useful functions allows you to build
metrics and dimensions for reporting and
visualizing
when you are ready to share your
conclusions data studio is ready with
you
with graphs charts pivot tables shapes
dynamic controls for customizing all of
your data
to get started quickly you can import
data from google ads
analytics youtube bigquery or just pull
in a csv or sheet
you can quickly invite others to view or
edit along with you
and embed the reports you make inside
websites presentations or blog posts
google data studio is free this levels
the business intelligence playing field
all fueled by the power of google cloud
so go ahead unite
all your data sources explore and
transform tell impactful stories that
help eliminate trends
and next time you're looking to do data
analysis for business intelligence
take a minute to look at data studio
[Music]
to learn more check out
[Music]
betastudio.google.com
you